this morning the social media site where
the alleged synagogue shooter posted
hateful messages is offline gab calm is
popular among white nationalists and in
the old right its CEO says nine million
people visit the site every month the
suspects biography on the site contained
the anti-semitic rhetoric in a statement
gab rode it unequivocally disavows and
condemns all acts of terrorism and
violence free speech is crucial for the
Prevention of violence CBS News
contributor and editor-in-chief of Wired
Nicholas Thompson is here with a look at
the responsibilities social media
platforms have when it comes to hate
speech Nick good morning John so why
didn't Gabe actor Lee er well Gavin very
much was founded on principles of free
speech absolutism if it's legal to say
something they will allow it on the
platform that is a very different
philosophy for most other social media
platforms right now one of their
principles did gab radicalize him do you
think is that even something that we
could even discuss or assume so that is
the most important question so it
happened is that all of the
infrastructure underneath gap so it's
hosting providers the payments providers
they all said yesterday we're done we're
not gonna protect you that's why gab is
knocked offline and in one way it's
strange that hosting providers get to
make the decision about a conversation
which people talk should they have that
power of a free speech if you think of
it as a free speech question it seems
strange but if as you said you think
about the question did gab radicalize
this person this gab bears some
culpability and turning him into the
person who did what he did then you
reach a very different conclusion
well the question about whether you can
be radical online radicalized online has
already been supported by our government
that's that's we believe that after 9/11
when people had access to Isis
supporters and those who are trying to
radicalize yeah isolated individuals we
know now that Facebook Twitter and
YouTube all have agreed with this and
have worked with the government to take
a lot of these videos down why not when
it comes to right or left wing
extremists online well for one it's very
hard it's hard to identify what is
extremism it's hard to identify what
exactly is hate speech words are very
complicated in different contexts in the
particular case of Bauer's yes it's very
easy to identify what he was doing he
should have been found it should have
been taken down but as a general
principle it's very difficult to
identify what is hate speech what is not
hate speech and to set firm policies on
that I mean here the the ADL which is
the anti-defamation league found at
least 4.2 million
anti-semitic tweets were shared or
Reshard in English on Twitter over a
12-month period how do you stop yes Nick
is when you say hate speech is hard to
identify online how is that hard to
identify
hate speech well hate speech is
complicated right because you look for
specific words and you look for the
context in which those words were said
so words that can be attacking one group
once said by a member of that group can
actually be affirmative right so it's
very hard to identify what is an actual
hate statement what is a lyric what is
something that can be positive so hate
speech is actually of the technical
problems the social media companies have
it is the hardest in a case like Bowers
yeah yeah take that guy offline and if
this platform is defending him you can
see why they want to take a whole
platform offline you've got to look very
closely and read in detail which we
can't do in this morning explain it but
look at the trail between what Bowers
was seeing on line and on TV about the
caravan believing that it was caused by
Jews and supported by hice and that's
when he then tweeted screw your optics
I'm going in there is a worse than art
corner this was yeah it's said by
politicians and I feel like it's even
worse the next I feel like not only does
he get radicalized
he'd get some affirmation yes post I'm
going in because he wants people to like
that there's something wrong with that
platform if that happens we got to go
here thank you very much Nicki for
helping us take a first cut at this